foreign
[Music]
myself as a brand I've had a lot of help
along the way it's actually funny
because I I'm actually my own agent so I
feel proud about it to have been able to
you know whether it's negotiate my last
deal and you know make some of the
decisions and be really in control of my
life but you know I've had a lot of help
you know people around me that have done
a great job like I said you know
teaching me I always go into the mindset
that I don't really know anything in
life you know there's always something
to learn so for me it has been like I
say it's been a learning experience you
know tough at times because you know
people have been doing that for a long
time and you know at times like you know
you need a little more but it's been fun
for me
the one thing that I learned from
negotiating my last year was that I'm in
control I felt good the only because it
was like you know you're going back and
forth that kind of I kind of saw because
I had a nation before so I never knew
how you know all those stuff I actually
went about so it was uh like I said
learning it going back to learning again
learning experience for me the kind of
see what goes on you know behind closed
doors or whatever they usually talk
about and actually be in the middle of
it and you know just going back and
forth and you know whether it's action
stuff and you know them action stuff if
there's one thing that I learned is that
I'm a tough negotiator so and whatever I
want I'm gonna get it
I think a challenge for me coming up in
the industry definitely has been like
try finding that work-life balance I
wanted to chase this because it's
something that I love but I think then
when you make something that's like a
passion your vocation it can be really
hard to to yeah just find balance and I
have had a lot of periods where I'm like
I'm doing what's making me happy I'm
doing what's making me happy and then
I'm doing what's making me happy all the
time and I'm not giving myself space to
like live and recharge because I also
can't expect myself to be at like my
creative best if I don't have an actual
life
the thing about like going from a nine
to five to making your own hours is
actually like my least favorite part uh
and the hardest part I feel like people
kind of don't realize if like you're
just freelancing forever even if you're
at like the highest level in your Fields
like in the Arts you're still kind of
always a freelancer and you're always
trying to you know make your own lane
and your own path in different places so
that sort of like instability I think is
what scared me initially and still makes
me a little nervous sometimes but can
also be cool it can also be nice to not
necessarily have like I don't know a
boss you have to report to or I don't
know like a weird
photocopy machine
[Music]
you know it can be really scary and you
don't want people to think you know
you're a sellout or or that they're
being like used in a way or that you're
just always selling something I think
slow and steady is definitely how I've
always thought about it like I'm not
trying to do 50 brand things a week and
I'm not trying to you know do a million
things at once I think it's really
important to know why the people that
are giving you their name like that are
actually following you and are invested
in you why they're there and I always
bring it back to like they're here for
these videos that hopefully make them
feel better and make them laugh so you
know as long as I'm doing that I feel
good about you know working with a brand
or you know doing something else or or
like I guess selling a product but I
just think it's important to always be
thoughtful about everything that you do
I really try to give everything like a
lot of thought and I hope that people
feel that and I think they do that I
really care and I'm not just trying to
like sell things because I feel so lucky
to do what I do I don't want to lose
that platform or or make make people
feel like they've been like cheated or
that they're just like there so I can
take their money that's like not the
point I want them to feel like they're a
part of it too I think a great example
is with Mac I I did a lipstick as my
character Jenny and people like
complimented Jenny on it and it was just
like this fun thing that we could share
of us being like our girl did it like
she has a lipstick and it just felt like
I don't know uh like the World building
around that was really fun for me and
and I think it felt more special to the
people you know that that have followed
me for a long time that a that I had
made like I had done the work to make
this lipstick and I was really proud of
like you know how it came out but that
also it's like a character did it there
was like a lot of thought in all of that
and I hope people feel that but I try to
always give things my attention and
treat the people that follow me like
people and not just a number
I think it can be hard sometimes because
I think the more that you open yourself
up on social media on places like tick
tock on Instagram you
open yourself up to more negativity and
more positivity and I think
sometimes when
your intention is to show people who you
are it's not always easy for people to
grasp through a screen
it was very important to me with my
brand that
there was so much of me weaved in
throughout the whole entire thing and I
do think people can feel that and I do
think they can see that it's very
genuine to me it's something I'm
extremely passionate about and I really
hoped that people would see that and
feel that through the brand and I do
think that's the takeaway and I hope
that it can continue to be the takeaway
but I do think there is a fine line of
maintaining a personal life in your
privacy and then
being open with people and being able to
be yourself and be vulnerable but I'm
still trying to figure that out
things staying true to yourself not
forgetting
like why you started your like main
goals I think it can get really
distracting with there's a lot of people
around you kind of telling you what they
think you should do or what you should
do like when I was starting I had people
say that like no one cared about the
base and I should like stop focusing on
that and like all that stuff and that
was just not
you know that's not what I believed in
that was like my passion also taking
time for yourself too and just making
sure that you're
you're feeling good mentally is the most
you know one of the most important
things too because if you're feeling
good then that's going to reflect in
like the work that you do
it's just like taking that time and
building and building in that extra time
for yourself so you don't kind of get
lost in it yeah and making sure that
you're you know you're supporting
yourself the best way you can like being
your own best friend is something I
always talk about and staying connected
with your with your body and your and
your spirit and your mind and why you
started all this in the first place and
just making sure that that doesn't get
lost I think that's like a way that I
set a boundaries just like okay this
doesn't
feel right to my vision or what I'm
trying to accomplish that's kind of what
I do
[Music]